Southern California that'll be a great
chat coming up in the middle of this
hour Tom Curren of NBC Sports Boston
back here on the Rich Eisen show Tom how
to call you with the Wickersham article
out there how are you Tom I'm always
happy to come on with you Rick thanks
thanks brother so let's get into it what
in your mind is the most unbelievable or
not to be believed facts that you read
in the wickersham article knowing the
team is you do
yeah the tom brady is kicking rocks
about not being named the player of the
week that would jump the page to me but
you know there's plenty in there and i
wrote about it exactly a week ago that
is spot on there's a level of tension
and uncertainty in Foxboro that is
fairly unprecedented and it's an
amalgamation of things which but more
than anything else it's a sense that you
have a 41 year old quarterback as of
this august you have a 65 year old head
coach and a 76 year old owner and you
have at this duster traded away a very
very very good backup quarterback who
certainly could have given certainty
going forward so all of those things
that Seth wrote about are accurate and
there's there's not a lot of
inaccuracies in it there are points that
I would contend and there's an overall
sense of palace intrigue and shipping
each other that I don't think exists you
know the notion that craft big-footed
Bill Belichick and said this is what
you're going to do I think is overstated
also there were no contract offers
formally cobbled together for Jimmy
Garoppolo and split across to his
representatives that were dismissed the
fact is they knew Jimmy wanted to play
they didn't even get to the point where
they were making contract offers if they
spit balled about what a contract would
look like that's one thing but they knew
he wasn't hanging around for a bridge
contract certainly not for seven million
dollars less than the franchise tag
which the Patriots would have to apply
to him Tom Curren of NBC Sports Boston
here on the Rich Eisen show what else
would you contend with from that article
then I would just say that there was
never an instance
from the reporting I've done rich where
Robert Kraft went to Bill Belichick and
said you have to trade Jimmy
nor was Tom Brady behind a move to do
that
Bill Belichick loved Garoppolo he even
said that in this concluding press
conference that we tried every way we
could to figure out a way to make this
work but in the end franchising a bridge
contract those two things wouldn't work
a for the team B for Garoppolo so the
booby prize in this is that you have to
trade one and the booby prize is that
you end up with what many consider the
greatest quarterbacks of all that to me
is and and I think that that has to be
understood
I don't think Bill Belichick really
needed to be persuaded to keep it but I
will say this when he references rich
that it was a complex situation I think
that alludes to the acknowledgement that
look this is not where Malloy and it's
not Rodney Harrison or Logan Mankins or
Richard Seymour this is a guy who still
plays at an MVP level that we've got all
that we owe a lot to maybe we don't go
out to dinner all the time but yeah I
don't think I can trade them either so
before we get to the what happens next
but still lingering the why are we here
in the first place of it all Tom Curren
so I'm trying to put all the pieces
together if if if I feel like this is
this is the few good men here if we
ordered Santiago to not be touched then
why was he touched and Garoppolo is the
Santiago hear of it Tom who ordered the
Code Red on Santiago was it Brady
was it Kraft I mean it's or you're
telling me the circumstances of it
because they didn't do everything to
keep him if they never offered on Yi
contract and slid it across the table
Tom so then why was Santiago touched Tom
that's a great question and a good way
of putting it I think you have to get up
on the highest tree and look down at it
they didn't fight him the contract
because they knew he wouldn't take it 17
million
dollars or 18 million dollars over four
years and then escalating when you
become the starter Jimmy sat there for
three years
we've seen we've seen in what in San
Francisco he's ready to go he he wasn't
interested in it and the spitballing
done or intimations that we're going to
make a contract offer I think would have
been met by save it we're not talking
bridge contracts here and the Patriots
didn't want to franchise them and deal
with forty six billion dollars worth of
quarterback expenditure and if they
extended Tom to try and reduce that
expenditure wouldn't that just be saying
to Jimmy and a donkey who represents
both yeah he's actually not going
anywhere guys so that's where it gets to
be a complex situation
why was the Code Red ordered I don't
think a Code Red was ordered I think
that they just came to a point where
Belichick threw up his hands and said
you know what we don't trade them now we
ain't franchising them because we can't
afford that and we're not gonna be able
to trade them in February because he's a
damn free agent in about thirty days
from then so nobody's gonna do that so
let's just send them to a good home I
hate to say that but that to me it
sounds implausible but when you really
think about it it is the only plausible
explanation Belichick didn't want to
trade either guy you traded the more
tradable what well then there's the this
opposition from the article about this
Tom is that maybe Belichick sitting
there saying okay Brady and the owner
have a love affair and I can't contend
with that and so let's get Garoppolo out
of here try and win right now I'm gonna
send him to a spot where he's gonna
flourish cuz he called San Francisco
coordinate this article he texted Kyle
Shannon who he has respect for let's
send him in a spot where I'm gonna look
pretty damn good and then I'm out of
here
I you know I don't want to deal with
Alex Guerrero anymore that I've got a
quarterback that's not the same anymore
I know the way this league works forty
one-year-old quarterbacks forty
two-year-old quarterbacks I don't care
about the avocado ice cream or whatever
or the pajamas that can help you get
better or you know by sleeping them
overnight I'm out of here
I mean so what about that Tom is that a
possibility from the people I've spoken
to
hmm they expect on Brady and Bill
Belichick to be with the team in
September 2018 there is among others
I've spoken to all people plugged in and
near the situation or other people I've
spoken to feel so unnerved by the
uncertainty of it the perception that
maybe Kraft big-footed Belichick that
feel like you know what maybe we should
get while the getting's good and that's
why the uncertainty I feel because their
clandestine not just with the media
their clandestine with each other and
when I say that I mean does the staff
doesn't know what's going on so that
unease about still gonna leave how many
years to still actually have left on his
contract that is all figured into this
and I think caused a lot of this
trepidation which is turned into you
know who's doing what to whom one other
thing I'll mention too is there is a
sense from the article that every time
Tom Brady and throws incomplete it's a
sign that he's 41 it can't just be
really true incomplete and I think that
exists here in New England especially in
light of having traded Garoppolo no
Brady has over the last five games not
played at the level he did at the
beginning of the year and I think the
supposition in in Foxborough it's like
when you're driving a car and it has a
knock oh my god how much is this gonna
cost me he can't be a little knock the
things that Brady is doing now that
don't look good on particular Sunday
same things he's done all throughout his
career but now it's that oh my god a
couple more minutes left with Tom Curren
of NBC Sports Boston so is it possible
that Bella checks on a walkie and we
don't even know it
is that possible My yes absolutely it's
possible my supposition is that's not
the case and again from folks who have
told me I expect them both around here
in 2018 that leads me to believe that
he's not but but here's the scoop to Tom
you know and I've you know dropped a
couple of breadcrumbs the of on Twitter
on this to question is do we have a low
for an
so but there's one job opening in the
NFL that would even give Belichick a
split second of thinking about that's
open right now and they also have the
number two overall pick and he knows he
and he knows the family that runs it and
the Giants job is open I have no idea of
gentlemen would even entertain the idea
with whatever contract he has or the
Giants would even entertain it but you
have to think they would
is there any there there to that sort of
sense Tom that Belichick and everything
would just throw his hands up and say
I'm just gonna finish up my career
somewhere else like the Giants if you
really besides that at 6566 he wants a
challenge I think that would be a hell
of a challenge because you have to take
Eli Manning out behind the barn
finish that job then you have to find a
new quarterback then you have to find
new coordinators because Josh certainly
isn't coming with you
additionally you have to feel
comfortable working with Dave gentlemen
who in my mind is one serious no BS kind
of guy who has an idea of how he wants
to do things I like the way gentlemen
operates he almost operates in a
Belichick gien Manor you know what I'm
in charge here
but unless they share a brain I don't
know if those two old dogs would
necessarily be able to combine and work
together I don't know what the
relationship is but that's what I look
at what the belts are gonna want to go
in after gentleman has probably been
given the keys to that franchise and
told to fix it and
[Music]
you know off gentlemen listen to
Gettleman that's why I think that's kind
of a non-starter okay
ask Tom countering the poll question
before we send him on the road and back
into the bomb cyclone hey Tom who's most
likely to end their career with the
Patriots most likely to end their career
with the Pats Belichick Brady neither go
check because if Brady wants to play
past 2019 when his contract expires he
may well have to do it elsewhere where
would that elsewhere be for you you know
you never know
which is always you know that that's the
funniest thing to is because that's
another breadcrumb that others who I
really respected like in the media have
offered to me it ain't a coincidence
that they sent them to San Francisco you
know it's it's it's full of intrigue and
look it's it's been unbelievable to
cover these guys and I think that the
supposition and presumption is when it
ends there's gonna be a lot of why did
this happen and there'll be a lot of you
know bloody knives to uncover at the
bottom of the garbage can who did what
to whom I don't think it's gonna be as
ugly as folks think but that doesn't
mean we're not going to talk about and
try and figure that out
tell me about it so in that regard
before I let you go when's the next time
Belichick and Brady have media
availabilities best you can tell when's
the next time that happens oh crap that
will be Thursday of next week Thursday
yeah the Triple H statement though I
know so whenever they do speak they
could say hey we put out a statement
next question all we hold on to will
fill in the blank okay both will
actually they'll have media villas
available 'ti Monday on the radio on
WEEI both guys do a hit then I'm sure
that they'll be some grunts and groans
we'll be plugged in thanks again Tom
happy New Year to you thanks for the
call you too buddy Tom Curren Oh Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience